Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In many episodes about computer graphics,
we explored works on how to simulate the motion
and the collision of different bodies. However,
sounds are just as important as visuals, and
there are really cool techniques out there
that take the geometry and material description
of such objects and they simulate how smashing
them together would sound like.
This one is a more sophisticated method which
is not only faster than previous works, but
can simulate a greater variety of materials,
and we can also edit the solutions without
needing to recompute the expensive equations
that yield the sound as a result.
The faster part comes from a set of optimizations,
most importantly something that is called
mesh simplification. This means that the simulations
are done not on the original, but vastly simplified
shapes.
The result of this simplified simulation is
close to indistinguishable from the real deal,
but is considerably cheaper to compute.
What is really cool is that the technique
also offers editing capabilities. You compute
a simulation only once, and then, edit and
explore as much as you desire.
The stiffness and damping parameters can be
edited without any additional work. Quite
a few different materials can be characterized
with this.
The model can also approximate a quite sophisticated
phenomenon where the frequency of a sound
is changing in time. One can, for instance,
specify stiffness values that vary in time
to produce these cool frequency shifting effects.
It is also possible to exaggerate or dampen
different frequencies of these sound effects,
and the results are given to you immediately.
This is meeting all my standards. Amazing
piece of work.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!